Hey, I think you'll find this hilariously
compelling.
Donald Trump, as many of you know, has been
accused of varying degrees of sexual assault
by a variety of women and girls.
The number, depending on how you categorize
them, could be twelve.
It could be 26.
Depends on where you draw the line in terms
of assault.
Donald Trump has versus just harassment, to
be clear.
Donald Trump has done everything possible
to shut these women up.
He's hired high priced lawyers.
He's used pay offs of six figures in combination
with non-disclosure agreements.
He's intimidated and threatened women.
The entire thing.
Joe Biden is also accused of sexual assault
by a woman most recently known as Tara Reid.
I guess the way I would say it, Joe Biden
has asked that a file search take place for
her name in a number of different files to
see if there's a record of this allegation
from 1993.
So Donald Trump's daughter in law, Lara Trump,
an advisor to the 2020 campaign.
If you can believe that goes on.
Fox News is Judge Jeanine Pirro Show and says
with a straight face.
If you were innocent, you would do anything
possible to clear your name, including opening
up files.
Irony is dead, my friends.
Take a look at this video.
While I don't think if if you were being accused
of something and you were totally innocent,
you would go to any length possible judge
to try and clear your name, including allowing
people to open up files like that and make
sure you turn over every single leaf to prove
your innocence and make sure that people understood
that these charges were false and that you
did nothing wrong.
So apply what she says to Donald Trump.
If Trump is innocent, he would do anything
possible to open the files to prove his innocence.
Except Trump paid to close the files.
As usual, the rules apply to everyone but
Trump himself.
There is a whole long list of Donald Trump's
accusers to whom this strategy could be applied.
And yet it's not.
It's the opposite.
Not opening files, paying to keep files closed,
using non-disclosure agreements to shut women
up.
Every tactic you can imagine.
Now, if Judge Jeanine Pirro were a serious
journalist or even just a serious commentator
who wants to be taken seriously, she should
have immediately said to Larry Trump, why
didn't Donald Trump do that when it came to
his 26 accusers?
Why hasn't Donald Trump opened the files on
anything or released women from non disclosures?
But Judge Jeanine is not a serious person.
But remember that Larry Trump's audience is
Trump himself and the Fox News crowd.
They don't care about the hypocrisy.
They don't care about the double standard.
And when presented with the allegations against
Trump, they don't care.
They are not reachable.
We've learned that over the last four years.
They're hypocrites and full of it.
But it doesn't matter when your own followers
won't hold you to account.
Why even bother being consistent or telling
the truth?
There is no reason to.
And while we're at it, this applies to Donald
Trump's taxes as well.
Remember?
Oh, yeah, I plan to release them.
Well, now I'm under audit, so I'll release
them when I'm not.
It's been four years, guys.
It's been five years.
I think since he started talking about whether
he would release those tax cuts.
Burns He's not going to be held accountable
by his supporters either.
So it's up to up to us to do
it
in November.